for those looking to be thoroughly
spooked Netflix is home to a wide array
of unsettling horror movies ranging
anywhere from gory slashes to tense
psychological thrillers to help you
navigate the vast amounts of Netflix
exclusives the platform has to offer
here's a list of the creepiest Netflix
films you should never watch alone after
the unexpected death of their friend a
group of old college buddies honor his
memory by taking a trip to Sweden
shortly after embarking on their hiking
journey one of the friends is injured
and the group decides to take a shortcut
through the forest after a series of
eerie occurrences the group becomes lost
turning what was supposed to be an
adventurous trip memorizing their lost
pal into a disturbing dangerous affair
the ritual is that its strongest when it
explores the relationships and
interactions between the friends as says
sanity begins to slip so does their
friendship showing just how fragile the
bond between friends can be the film
offers a perfect blend of a good story
creepy imagery and the cast of likable
characters a natural airiness of the
forest the growing tension as a group
becomes more lost and increasingly worse
for wear and the inclusion of a
sacrificial cold sore make for a
wonderfully fighting flick just be
careful about watching it before taking
any trips out to the forest in Hersh
Matty Young is a deaf-mute author who
has moved into our moat house to write
our next book in peace and fortunately
for the author she gets trapped in a
twisted life-or-death scenario when a
stranger with a crossbow finds her
isolated home not only as hosts one of
the best horror films on Netflix is also
one of the most suspenseful films on the
home invasion sub-genre director Mike
Flanagan expertise in tension building
and creepy storytelling shine through
effortlessly and hush especially with
the film's use of sound because Maddy is
dev push uses a natural sound of a scene
to help induce panic in the audience
viewers listening closely to the film
will be able to catch specific cues that
escape the main character
before I wake follows Jessie and her
husband Mark who taken a foster child
named Cody
after their son passes away once Cody
moves in it becomes apparent to the new
parents that Cody is reluctant to sleep
turns out that's a good reason Cody's
dreams become reality which is
especially awkward as he keeps dreaming
about that dead son when Cody begins to
dream of Jesse's deceased child the
dynamic in the house immediately changes
a parents struggle with accepting the
passing of their son when he keeps
appearing in front of them at night but
once Cody's dreams turned to nightmares
the tone of the film changes from
fantastical to terrifying in an attempt
to rekindle their failing marriage
Jessie and her husband Gerald take a
vacation to the lake house shortly after
arriving Gerald decides to engage in
some adventurous bedroom activity but he
has a heart attack immediately after he
handcuffs Jessie leaving her completely
trapped and find her bed Jessie must
find a way to escape while also facing
off against a starving dog and an
ominous houseguest that visits her at
night
Gerald's game is a brutal film to watch
because of the sheer helplessness of the
protagonist rather film her drive to
stay alive and to free herself creates a
sense of optimism throughout the film
but the obstacles in her way are
absolutely brutal well for James lives
on a farm with his wife Arlette and
teenage son Henry though Wilfred and
Henry had told a simple life
Arlette has other plans for the family
after she expresses her intent to sell
the farm and move to the city with Henry
tensions quickly rise in the household
with limited options Wilfred concludes
that to keep his land he must kill his
wife
19:22 dives into the mind of a man
willing to kill for his own personal
game the film frames a narrative through
Wilfred's telling of events his inner
monologue so eloquent and almost poetic
the Wilfred is truly an unnerving
character to follow well this is a
saying I regret
me even more bitterly than the crime for
regions at dis document will show more
terrifying than the killing itself is
how Wilfred's violent plot affects him
and the people he loves in ways he never
believed possible the film doesn't shy
away from showcasing the consequences of
Welf words to pray factions and if
you're looking for a slow burn horror
film with a menacing main character 1922
is definitely worth for watch the
perfection focuses on Charlotte's are
now
cellist who was forced to leave an elite
conservatory when Charlotte begins a
relationship with Elizabeth the new
prodigy from the same music school
things quickly spiral out of control the
perfection is genuinely unsettling
primarily due to the strong acting of
the two lead actresses both managed to
be likable and unpredictable and it
makes for a wild ride for viewers of the
film with plenty of graphic imagery and
disturbing implications the perfection
still manages to be a thought-provoking
watch kam follows Alice a cam girl who
aspires to rise to the top ranks of a
Congo website after she fakes killing
herself on one of her shows Alice's
account has hacked by a person who looks
and sounds identical to her to get her
show back and regain her identity Alice
must find the source of the copycat
hacker not only is Cameron premise the
film smartly comments and how women are
treated in the adult video industry
alice is an extremely likable confident
woman who is proud of her job as a cam
girl and the audience she has acquired
the creepiness in cam largely stems from
how easily someone's work and identity
can be stolen online Alice's life is
instantly destroyed and there seemingly
nothing she can do to protect herself
considering just how easily accounts and
even major corporations could be hacked
online the implications in cam should be
more than enough to make everybody
delete their social media accounts and
permanently log off Byrd Boggs takes
place in a frightening universe for
creatures Drive anyone who looks at them
to insanity to avoid this fate a
survivors must stay indoors and cover
their eyes when navigating outdoors
Mallory an expectant mother
drones a group of survivors and hopes of
safely waiting out the storm with a
child on the way and dwindling resources
among the crew Mallory must not only
protect herself but also find a way to
safely raise her newborn child in the
post-apocalyptic world bird bugs
presents a fascinating premise where
survivors must restrict the use of their
ice forcing them to find new ways to go
on with their daily lives
most of the horror stems from having
characters walk around blindly all while
mentally and see where people are trying
to kill them but the themes of
motherhood and the fears associated with
it at an extra level of horror that
viewers are likely to find very
unsettling serial killers are a staple
of the horror genre a more offer than us
we associate them with monsters like
Michael Myers and Jason Voorhees rather
than real-life human beings but in
extremely wicked shockingly evil and
vile the focus isn't on some fictional
slasher but instead on Ted Bundy the
infamous serial killer who murdered at
least 30 women throughout the 1970s the
film highlights Ted Bundy in his
relationship with his girlfriend that
lists Kendall as they were
the police has grown suspicions of Bundy
unknown to Liz Ted is actively murdering
people while they're together and
constantly spitting lies to avoid
detection
what makes extremely wicked shockingly
evil and vile and especially chilling
watch isn't gory killings or tense
action set-pieces
it's just how charismatic this killer is
Ted Bundy was an actual killer who
killed real people often by manipulating
his victims into a false sense of
security and preying on their good well
whoever this woman is who's accusing you
I'm sure she's just got me mixed up with
another handsome stranger certainly
Australian outback cargo follows the
trials and tribulations of Andy a man
who survived a zombie apocalypse
along with his baby daughter Rosie
unfortunately and he's recently been
bitten and he only has a matter of hours
before he turns into one of the undead
with precious little time left and his
priority is to find someone to raise his
daughter after he turns into one of the
Walking Dead unlike many other zombie
films our hero Andy is bitten early on
fated to die as Andy's time diminishes
and he becomes more like the undead we
see not just a decline of society but
the fracturing of the family units cargo
plays on the fear of complete isolation
and being mostly responsible for your
own survival and able to seek out the
help of others in society in a passel
codesys living on a remote islands
kidnap a girl and hold her for ransom
sent on a mission to rescue his sister
Thomas Richardson makes his way to the
island to safer while covertly living
among the cult members
Thomas must navigate the island
stealthily and play the role of a devout
follower one of the bloodiest movies on
Netflix a film features horrific rituals
creepy creatures and impressive action
scenes and when our hero discovers the
full extent of what's happening on this
island he realizes he's caught up in
something much darker than he bargained
for as the film progresses the beliefs
of the cults are slowly revealed and the
aggressive enforcement of those ideas
helped to create a sense of imminent
dread for much of the film apostle is
the perfect creepy film for any viewer
that's at once terrified and fascinated
by cult life I am the pretty thing that
lives in the house follows the story of
Lily Saylor a live-in nurse who's hired
to assist iris Blum a retired writer
with dementia once Lily begins to settle
into the old house a series of strange
events start to occur like mold
appearing on the walls and figures of
ghosty beings roaming the halls after
finding a draft of one of irises books
detailing a murdered couple who once
lived in the house Lily begins to
suspect that the account isn't fictional
and that the
might be haunted co-founder paranormal
thrillers I am the pretty thing that
lives in the house makes excellent use
of the haunted mansions creepy
atmosphere with plenty of slow pans and
dark lighting instead of relying on jump
scares and constant threats the film is
more reverse slowly building up the
paranormal happenings and irises home
for viewers who may be tired of watching
tween shrieking at cg ghost inspectors
the film offers a refreshing change of
pace that still likely to keep you awake
at night while serial killers gory jests
and dark lighting or make for a creepy
experience sometimes the scariest
scenarios are films psychological
elements in clinical dr. J Mathis is a
psychiatrist struggling to move on with
her life after she's attacked by one of
her patients but let lessly tortured by
the idea that she failed in her role as
a psychiatrist
Jane steps away from treating trauma
patients to focus on her own well-being
just as she's beginning to make progress
Jane receives a request from a man
suffering from trauma after an intense
automobile accident moved by the man's
plight Vanessa agrees to help him but
doing so has his consequences trying to
juggle her mental hull while also
fulfilling her promise to her new
clients begins to take a toll what
separates this creepy deltax horror film
from other movies is that it plays with
a concept of how scary a person's own
minds can be when they're not in control
of it that's the figures manifesting
during sleep paralysis and that unstable
reality will come into play
showing that sometimes a most severe and
dangerous struggles are constructed
inside our own minds check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]